mais pas de là comme un calque mercier
ou madame la présidente
j'ai le plaisir de présenter la
déclaration pré enregistrés du président
mahmoud abbas président de l'état de
palestine
devant la 66ème session de l'assemblée
générale je vous souhaite plein succès
ce qui est de relever les défis auxquels
nous sommes tous confrontés
dans le monde comme dans l'état de
palestine merci
c'est même si ce excellence alors que
nous attendons de la part en nous
attendant la vidéo du chef de l'état de
palestine
en attendant que ceux disponibles là
nous allons peut-être devoir passer à
l'orateur suivant donc je vous demande
quelques instants
au nom de dieu le clément le
miséricordieux
votre excellence monsieur de lashari
président de l'assemblée générale des
nations unies donc c'est moi ce mot si
antonio gutiérrez secrétaire général des
nations unies
à beaune en live too big to fall guène
de 10 observée je vais à nouveau donné
la parole à l'observateur de l'état
observateurs nos palestine qui va
présenter la déclaration du chef d'état
vous avez la parole monsieur
saint mary's madame la présidente
j'ai le plaisir de présenter la
déclaration pré enregistrés de son
excellence mahmoud abbas président de
l'état de palestine devant la 66ème
session de l'assemblée générale
je souhaite plein succès à cette section
pour relever les défis auxquels le monde
et notre peuple sont confrontés
le monde a les yeux tournés vers nous
afin que nous accomplissons notre devoir
et que nous exercions leurs droits merci
au nom de dieu le clément le
miséricordieux instruction spéciale de
la chaîne président de l'assemblée
générale des nations unies en tant que
selon ce monsieur a tenu un goûter rush
certains générale des nations unies
vos excellences mesdames et messieurs
les chefs de délégations membres de
délégations mesdames et messieurs
que la plaie la bénédiction et la
clémence de dieu soit sur vous cette
année et le 63e anniversaire de la nakba
plus de la moitié du peuple palestinien
était expulsé de ses terres et privés de
leurs biens moi même ma famille et de
nombreux autres faux selon toujours les
titres de notaire
ces titres sont enregistrés font partie
des archives de l'onu
voici ce titre
et de nombreux palestiniens
ont les leurs
tout comme ils ont toujours les clés de
leur maison à ce jour même
néanmoins nous n'avons pas été capables
de recouvrer nos biens en raison des
lois israéliennes qui ignore le droit
international et qui viole les
résolutions des nations unies qui
affirme le droit des réfugiés
palestiniens à revenir dans leurs foyers
et et à recouvrer leurs biens et
recevoir une juste compensation comme
cela est consacré dans la résolution
194 de l'assemblée générale
israël la puissance occupante au
contraire promulguer des lois pour
déplacer de force de manière illégale
depuis chercheurs rae silwan à jérusalem
ce que l'on ne peut décrire au titre du
droit international comme la
purification ethnique
ceux qui rejetaient par notre peuple
ainsi que la communauté internationale
dans son ensemble et représente un crime
au titre du droit international cette
année marque également
54e anniversaire de l'occupation
militaire israélien du reste des
territoires palestiniens en cisjordanie
y compris jérusalem-est et la bande de
gaza en 1967
cette occupation continue
malgré la conclusion d'un accord de
principe appelé des accords d'oslo afin
de parvenir à la paix à la
reconnaissance mutuelle avec israël en
1984 aise nous restons attachés à tous
ces éléments à ce jour et nous avons
donné leur accord à tout à fait
l'initiative pour parvenir à une
solution politique sur la base de
légitimité internationale y compris
l'initiative de paix arabe de 2002 et
est la feuille de route du quatuor de
2003 mais israël n'a pas honoré ses
obligations
au titre des accords signés et a refusé
de participer à des initiatives de paix
au contraire elle a mené son entreprise
expansionniste et colonial et a détruit
la perspective d'un règlement politique
sur la base d'une solution à deux états
à ceux qui affirment qu'il n'y a pas de
partenaire palestinien pour la paix et
que nous ne ratons jamais une occasion
de rater une occasion
eh bien je les mets au défi de démontrer
que nous avons rejeté ne serait-ce que
une initiative authentique et sérieuse
ils ont à parvenir à la paix
et j'accepte le jugement du monde à cet
égard
mesdames et messieurs
la puissance occupante israélienne
pense-t-elle qu'elle pourra échapper à
ses responsabilités pour les crimes
d'avoir expulsé plus de la moitié du
peuple palestinien de ses terres pour le
fait d'avoir commis d'innombrables
massacre d'avoir tué et mutilé des
milliers de palestiniens en 1948
pas là de chair deir yassin à bouchoucha
fans tour à el zaytoun kabia le d'autres
endroits
pense-t-elle qu'elle échappera ses
responsabilités pour la destruction
ultérieure de plus de 500 villes et
villages palestiniens israël pense qu'il
peut simplement ignoré les droits
légitimes y compris les droits
politiques de million de palestiniens
en palestine comme à l'extérieur
les propriétaires et les fils et filles
de cette terre qui à jérusalem en son
coeur essentielle que poursuivre sa
politique de vol de leurs terres d'
étranglement de l'économie et les
empêcher de respirer l'air de la liberté
israël pensait lequel peut sans fin
promouvoir un faux récit qui ignore les
droits historiques et actuelles du
peuple palestiniens à leur terre
les crimes et les politiques agressives
de la puissance occupante israélienne
contre notre peuple notre terre et nos
lieux saints
n'empêchera pas notre peuple de lutter
pour réaliser leur liberté leur
indépendance sur leurs terres le régime
colonial établie par israël sur notre
terre disparaîtra peu importe combien de
temps cela prendra
nous ne leur permettrons pas de
détourner nos vies et de tuer les rêves
de notre peuple leurs espoirs leurs
aspirations enfin de réaliser la liberté
l'indépendance mesdames et messieurs il
est regrettable que les et politique de
la communauté internationale
et les résolutions des organes
pertinents des nations unies concernant
une solution à la question de la
palestine
jusqu'ici n'est pas été défendu et mises
en oeuvre le résultat est un échec pour
ce qui est de tenir comptable israël
et de le sanctionner pour ses violations
du droit international
cela permet à israël qui affirme être un
état démocratique
d'agir comme un état au-dessus du droit
mesdames et messieurs il est toujours
certains pays qui refuse de reconnaître
la réalité c'est à dire qu israël est
une puissance occupante
qui pratique
l'apartheid et le nettoyage ethnique cpi
disent fièrement qu'ils ont des valeurs
communes avec israël mais de quelles
valeurs communes parle-t-il
de quelles valeurs communes par le tilt
cela
a rendu israël arrogant cela encourage
et à rejeter a violé toutes les
résolutions des nations unies
par ailleurs
certains exigent du peuple des
institutions palestiniennes
qui croient en la culture de paix et en
l'état de droit qui exige de qu'elle
fournisse des explications et
justifications pour démontrer qu'il
n'incite pas à la haine ou qu'il ne
promeuvent pas la violence par exemple
nous devons expliquer justifier
ce qu'il ya dans nos programmes
scolaires
ce qui reflète notre récit national à
notre identité nationale alors que
personne
mais ici je ne passe en revue les
programmes scolaires et les médias
israéliens
c'est là que le monde pourrait voir le
véritable incitation de la part des
institutions israéliennes
nous rejetons
ce deux poids deux mesures
nous rejetons ce deux poids deux mesures
pourquoi devrions nous apporter des
précisions justifier le fait d'aider les
familles des prisonniers et des martyrs
qui sont des victimes
de l'occupation et de ses politiques
d'oppression nous ne pouvons pas à
mesdames et messieurs abandonner notre
peuple
et nous continuerons nos efforts tant
que nos prisonniers n'auront pas été
libéré et ici je salue l'héroïsme de ces
prisonniers si l'occupation prend fin
il n'y aura plus de questions des
prisonniers
je ne peux que me demandais alors que je
m'adresse à toutes les personnes dotées
de conscience de par le monde et y at il
quelqu'un sur cette terre qui punirait
les morts et empêchera leur famille de
les enterrait
six et les personnes privées de moralité
d'humanité
combien de temps sait tu sors c'est déjà
la justice historique route notre peuple
continuera-t-elle les états qui
fournissent une aide financière et
militaire à israël qu'il utilise pour
prolonger son occupation et tuer
les palestiniens
est ce que ceux qui restent silencieux
face aux politiques agressives d'israël
son siège son et tendrement des
palestiniens c est à un style vraiment
qu'elle garantisse la paix la sécurité
pour le peuple israélien la stabilité
pour la région
la réponse est non et je le dis ici très
clairement
un nom absolument limpide que voulez
vous de plus du peuple palestinien nous
avons respecté tous nos obligations au
titre des résolutions des nations unies
nous avons nous sommes forcés
à supporter les souffrances qu'on nous a
imposée dans l'est
tente de l'espoir qu'elle a été le
résultat les éléments historiques au fil
des décennies ont prouvé que ces
politiques internationales par rapport à
israël
ne sont pas appropriés mesdames et
messieurs
dans le cadre de l'unification de notre
front intérieur nous répétons une fois
de plus que l'organisation de libération
de palestine est leur seul représentant
légitime du peuple palestinien
le soulignons que nous sommes attachés à
l'unité de notre peuple du notaire
nous nous engageons organiser les
élections législatives et
présidentielles et du conseil national
dès qu' il sera possible de le faire à
jérusalem au titre des accords signés
nous appelons la communauté
internationale à nous aider à faire
pression sur la puissance occupante pour
faire en sorte que ces élections aient
lieu à jérusalem
en effet
il est impossible d'imaginer que nous ne
puissions pas organiser des élections
une fois de plus je le répète nous
n'avons pas annulé les élections nous
n'avons fait que les reportée car nous
ne pouvions pas les organiser à
jérusalem tant que l'on n'aura pas
remédier à cette situation nous
continuerons à nous efforcer de créer
les conditions nécessaires
pour constituer
un gouvernement d'unité nationale
afin que nous puissions aider notre
peuple partout et afin que nous
puissions mettre en oeuvre les plans de
reconstruction dans la bande de gaza
ce qui exige
la fin totale de l'agression dans
l'ensemble du territoire
de l'état de palestine
je suis heureux de répéter que dans les
mois à venir nous n'ouvrons
l'organisation d'élections municipales
conformément à la loi et les élections
pour tous les syndicats et pour que les
universités sont déjà en cours
mesdames et messieurs
concernant
l'édification des institutions de l'état
nous soulignons que nous avons un état à
part entière
avec des institutions qui agissent
conformément à l'état de droit et au
principe de reddition de comptes de
transparence de démocratie et de
pluralisme du respect des droits de
l'homme et d'autonomisation des femmes
et des jeunes
nous sommes devenus parties à plus de
115 instruments juridiques et
organisations internationales il nous
sommes engagés à respecter les droits de
notre peuple et renforcer notre
législation est notre réglementation y
compris ceux qui ont trait aux droits de
l'homme
nous poursuivrons notre tentative visant
à
rejoindre
ce qui reste des cinq sens organisation
internationale reconnue par l'onu nous
avons pris des initiatives devraient
conjointement avec les organisations des
droits de l'homme la société civile et
ses organisations en palestine pour
préserver ses réalisations nationales
et pour améliorer le fonctionnement de
nos institutions
sur la base de l'état de droit
j'ai donné des instructions pour que
l'on prenne les mesures nécessaires
pour corriger tout or
pour continuer à respecter l'état de
droit à la liberté d'expression et les
droits de l'homme
telle est la voie à laquelle nous sommes
engagés dans mon pays je réaffirme la
communauté internationale notre
engagement en faveur les engagements
politiques et du dialogue
c'est la voie pour parvenir à la paix
et pour une résistance populaire
pacifique la voie pour lutter contre le
terrorisme sous toutes ses formes de
toutes origines dans notre région comme
dans le monde
nous avons
plus de 80 trois accords avec d'autres
pays du monde pour lutter contre le
terrorisme international mesdames et
messieurs je voudrais ici parler du
dialogue constructif actuellement en
cours avec l'administration des états
unis
pour reprendre les relations entre la
palestine et les états unis
il faut prendre des mesures qui feront
en sorte que la puissance occupante
respecte les accords signés pour notre
part nous nous engageons à garantir le
succès de ce dialogue pour créer des
conditions propices
fait d'avancer rapidement vers un
règlement politique finale qui met un
terme à l'occupation israélienne de
notre pays
j'ai qui verra l'application d'une
solution à deux états cependant le
gouvernement actuel comme son
prédécesseur
se sont constamment dérobé à une
solution à deux états sur la base du
droit international et des résolutions
des nations-unies exemple ainsi c'est
pour poursuivre l'occupation le contrôle
militaire du peuple palestinien
tout en présentant des plans économique
et sécuritaire non concluant comme une
alternative ses plans unilatéraux ne
permettront pas parvenir à la sécurité
la stabilité pour qui que ce soit en
effet ils sapent les efforts en faveur
d'une véritable paix prolonger
l'occupation
et confirme la réalité d'un état
d'apartheid
mesdames et messieurs
le moment de vérité est arrivée pour la
puissance occupante
il semble que nous sommes à la croisée
des chemins
nous en avons assez la situation ne peut
pas continuer et notre peuple ne peut
plus la supporter
j'ai consacré ma vie à la réalisation de
la paix et j'ai choisi le voit
d'activité pacifique légal et
diplomatique dans les enceintes
internationales nous avons tendu la main
de nombreuses reprises pour la paix mais
nous n'arrivons toujours pas à trouver
un partenaire à israël qui croient en
une solution d etat elle accepte les
dirigeants d'israël aujourd'hui
non plus la moindre honte quand de
manière arrogante
ils rejettent cette solution
qui jouit d'un consensus mondial
je lance un avertissement
sap est la solution à deux états sur la
base du droit international et des
résolutions des nations-unies cela
ouvrira la voie à d'autres options qui
nous seront imposés par la situation sur
le terrain
et suit la poursuite de l'occupation
israélienne de notre état
l'absence d'une solution juste aux
souffrances de 7 millions de réfugiés
palestiniens expulsés de leurs terres en
1948 le vol systématique des terres
palestiniennes et les crimes qui se
poursuivent de l'occupation et de la
démolition les maisons comme moyen de
châtiments collectifs
les meurtres la détention de milliers de
personnes y compris des femmes les
personnes malades et les enfants
le cycle l'imposition d'un blocus
inhumain à la bande de gaza à un blocus
injuste
et les mesures d'annexion sous de
nombreux prétextes de nombreux noms y
compris le plan de colonisation qu'ils
ont inventé dans la ville de jérusalem
et que nous rejetons totalement
tout cela a lié au crime du déplacement
de force des palestiniens depuis leurs
terres dans le cadre d'une politique de
discrimination raciale et de nettoyage
ethnique
menée par l'occupation en l'absence
d'une riposte internationale dissuasive
notre peuple on
n'acceptera pas la réalité de
l'occupation et de ses politiques et
pratiques illégales
nous poursuivrons notre juste lutte
pauvre notre droit à l'autodétermination
et il y a des options y compris le
retour à une solution basée sur le plan
de partage de la résolution 181 de 1947
qui donne à l'état de palestine 44%
militaire
c'est-à-dire deux fois les territoires
avec lesquels nous nous sommes retrouvés
après 1967 nous rappelons à chacun que
israël
a saisi par la force militaire la moitié
des terres qui avait été prévu pour
l'état de palestine en 1948
cette solution serait conforme à la
légitimité internationale si les
autorités d'occupation israël elle
continue à confirmer cette réalité
d'année et à l'apartheid comme c'est le
cas aujourd'hui notre peuple palestinien
à l le monde entier ne tolérerons pas à
cette situation et les circonstances sur
le terrain imposeront inévitablement
les droits politiques
égaux pour tous sur le terre de la poly
destine historique dans le cadre d'un
seul état
quoi qu'il en soit israël doit choisir
telles sont les options et israël doit
choisir
mesdames et messieurs
genou droit international prévoit le
droit à une vie libre et digne et
appelle les états à prendre les mesures
nécessaires pour protéger garantir ce
droit
en effet cette protection représente un
élément indispensable et décisif pour le
maintien de la paix de la sécurité de la
stabilité et du développement
à cet égard j'appelle
le secrétaire général antonio goûter
rech
le vrai sur la base des
résolutions pertinentes des nations
unies sur la protection y compris la
résolution adoptée lors de la séance
d'urgence de l'assemblée générale qui a
eu lieu en juin 2010 8
intitulé unies pour la paix je l'appelle
chapelle sera générale à prendre toutes
les mesures nécessaires pour élaborer un
mécanisme international de protection
comme cela est prévu dans son rapport
d'août 2018 et je l'appelle à activer ce
mécanisme
aux frontières de l'état occupés de
palestine y compris jérusalem-est pour
conférer à notre peuple une protection
internationale
parallèlement à cela et conformément à
la résolution dont j'ai parlé j'appelle
le saboteur général a
organisé une conférence de paix
internationale conformément au mandat
internationalement reconnue et aux
résolutions des nations unies et à
l'initiative de paix arabe et sous les
seuls auspices du quatuor international
du moyen-orient
mesdames et messieurs
pour faire en sorte que cette initiative
est une date butoir
nous donnons à israël la puissance
occupante un an pour se retirer des
territoires palestiniens qu'elle a
occupés en 1967 y compris jérusalem est
nous sommes prêts à oeuvrer pendant sept
années à la délimitation des frontières
afin de régler toutes les questions qui
trouvent du statut final sous les
auspices du quatuor international et
conformément aux résolutions des nations
unies
si cela n'est pas fait
pourquoi continuer à reconnaître israël
dans le cadre des frontières de 1967
pourquoi continuer à le reconnaître
de plus
nous irons devant la cour
de justice internationale qui est lors
d'un visiteur le plus important
internationalement
pour def contester la légitimité de
l'occupation des terres d'un état
palestinien ainsi que les applications
pertinents de l'onu et des états du
monde à cet égard
toutes les parties
devront respecter l'arrêt de la cour
le colonialisme
l'occupation et l'apartheid sont
interdits au titre du droit
international il s'agit de crimes si on
confond qu'il faut confronter c'est une
structure qu'il faut démanteler
l'appui la communauté internationale à
cette initiative conformément au droit
international et aux résolutions des
nations unies pourrait sauver la région
d'un sombre avenir inconnu nous avons la
chance de vivre dans la paix la sécurité
d'avoir des relations de bon voisinage
de vivre chacun de notre propre état
et le fait de retarder la mise en oeuvre
de ces mesures
maintiendra la région dans une situation
de troubles et l'instabilité avec de
graves conséquences
les dirigeants d'israël
rêvent-ils de conserver leurs
occupations a jamais
veulent t'ils que cette occupation dure
pour toujours mesdames et messieurs
pourquoi est-ce qu'un palestinien
devrait continuer à vivre soit sous
l'occupation raciste d'israël ou comme
un réfugié dans les pays voisins est-ce
qu'il n'y a pas d'autre option
la liberté par exemple
les palestiniens partout sont créatifs
ce sont des personnes innovante qui
travaille beaucoup qui sont dynamiques
et le monde entier peut-on à tester les
palestiniens méritent de vivre libres
dans leurs pairs sur l'auteur depuis
cette tribune j'appelle les fils et les
filles des palestiniens partout dans le
monde a continué
leur lutte pacifique et populaire
qui a montré qu'elle était le véritable
visage du courageux peuple palestinien
luttant pour la liberté et
l'indépendance en résistant à
l'occupation et l'apartheid
je salue notre club partout je soler
tous les pays
qui se sont montrés solidaires de notre
peuple
pendant
la révolte de jérusalem et la révolte
des prisonniers contre l'agression qui a
tué des centaines de personnes
qui à semer la destruction et qui a
causé le déplacement de milliers de nous
resituer concitoyens en cisjordanie et
jérusalem et dans la bande de gaza je
salue également tous ceux qui ont
participé
aux manifestations aux états unis et en
europe et partout dans le monde pour
exiger
la fin de l'occupation israélienne de
l'apartheid et du nettoyage ethnique
c'est pour exiger la justice liberté et
l'autodétermination pour notre peuple
il s'agit d'une prise de conscience
pour savoir ce qu'est vraiment
l'histoire de la palestine et je vous
exhorte tous à continuer à défendre
cette véritable histoire à défendre les
droits des palestiniens à la liberté à
l'égalité et à l'état
critiqué les politiques agressives les
pratiques agressives de la puissance
occupante israélienne et les colons
israéliens à de récit sioniste mais en
général ce n'est pas un acte d'
incitation ou d'antisémitisme au
contraire c'est le devoir
de chaque homme et femme libre dans le
monde à cet égard
je voudrais transmettre à la commission
internationale notre reconnaissance et
notre appréciation pour leur appui
politique et matériel à notre peuple
que pour l'édification de nos
institutions et de notre économie
nationale mais le temps est venu de
prendre des mesures concrètes pour
réveiller l'espoir à mettre un terme à
l'occupation israélienne de notaire de
notre peuple
et pour consolider les valeurs de
justice et de paix dans notre région je
me demande
ce qui empêche certains pays les pays
qui reconnaissent israël de reconnaître
l'état de palestine
puisqu'il soutient une solution à deux
états et jeudi le dirigeant israélien
nos prix mais pas acculer pas le peuple
palestinien ne le privez pas de sa
dignité et de son droit à ses terres à
son état parce qu'un si vous détruire et
où notre patience la patience de notre
peuple est en train d'atteindre ses
limites je répète une fois de plus que
le peuple palestinien défendra son
existence et son identité il ne se
rendra pas il ne mettra pas un genou en
terre il ne partira pas il restera sur
ses terres il le défendra il défendra
son destin afin d'arriver à mettre un
terme à l'occupation
l'occupation
des terres de l'état de palestine et de
sa capitale jérusalem est nous nous
disons une fois de plus c'est notre
terre c'est notre jérusalem c'est notre
identité palestinienne et nous les
défendrons jusqu'à ce que l'occupant
s'en aille car l'avenir nous appartient
et vous ne pouvez pas revendiquer la
paix la sécurité rien que pour vous
permettez-nous d'exister que la paix
soit avec vous
[Applaudissements]
ownby afin de dire au nom de l'assemblée
générale je tiens à remercier le
président de l'état de palestine pour ça
des portions dalo question
nous allons poursuivre le débat général
l'assemblée va entendre une allocution
de son excellence charles michel
président du
conseil européen de l'union européenne
je prie le protocole